[Music]
coming to you from his house in Los
Angeles its Odin we then is broken
I'm Andy Richter everybody Conan O'Brien
here Wow already Thursday this is our
fourth show hard to believe this week is
really flying by no it's not nobody is
saying no one no one's used that phrase
once since the quarantine went into
effect really flying by this week I tell
you but we are having fun and things are
actually moving a little more quickly
than I thought wonderful week shows and
tonight Sean Hayes is joining us
thrilled to have him we've been getting
terrific guests to to pipe up and join
us in this madness really a wonderful
time odd circumstances to be doing a
show I have to say I had a friend the
other day asked me Conan is it going to
be weird to be doing a show and telling
jokes and not getting a reaction and I
said I've been doing that for 26 years
good because I don't get a lot of laughs
that's the joke there anyway I did ask
my family if they would help me out by
applauding when I walked into a room
because I missed the applause I said hey
do you guys mind applauding when I walk
into the room and they thought about and
they said here's a compromise will
applaud when you walk out of a room so
they hate me but all of us are in the
same boat we're getting through this the
best we can we're finding little ways to
amuse ourselves I've taken up whittling
that's something I've been doing lately
I don't know if you guys are into it but
it's fun you just get a piece of wood
and catch yourself a knife and you just
start working away on the edges
a little bit and then you can start to
kind of dive down and get into a little
more detail as you go patience patience
is key because it doesn't happen quickly
it's something that takes time and
you're gonna make mistakes I've just
begun I'm not very good at it but I do
the best that I can and then you get you
know just something like this like I
said I'm just starting out just trying
yeah that's the caliber of the stuff
we're gonna be doing here on the show
that's called the old switcheroo knee
you've been in the business for a while
you're familiar with the old switcheroo
knee he's got one block of wood but then
he's got something oh yeah okay okay you
were way out of me I don't want to waste
your time because that's not my purpose
and I don't need to I don't need to
waste time because we have so much good
comedy and television for you if you can
even call this television anymore I
don't know what it is but we have great
infotainment for you this evening now I
want to do something useful in this part
of the program up top I thought I'd do a
public service message for all those
essential workers out there who are on
the road updates for the LA area right
now it looks like 405 is clear 134 clear
101 clear the i-10 clear the 110 clear
210 clear I five clear 60 clear highway
1 clear 105 clear 710 clear 605 clear
route to clear 15 clear 215 clear Mike :
clear back to you
chatting Sheila